matt your wife is your business partner
yes you've talked about that sheena so
let's get into that a little bit so uh
when your wife is your business partner
how do you manage
the wife side of things versus the
business side of things like how does
the marriage work and the business work
explain that so there's four or five
major tasks at our level that has to get
done no matter what
uh uh actually five she takes two i take
two we overlap on one okay so she has
her role she has and if you go to our
office she's got one side of the office
all the way down the hallways then my
outside office so there's there's space
right so what are those five things um
uh
i'm in charge of recruitment and
leadership development on the business
on business side of things okay um i'm
in charge of um i'm in charge of uh
uh making sure that the uh the marking
side of things are flowing and she's in
charge of the one so i'm the one to many
and she's got a lot of the one-to-one
goals because that's what she excels in
so she's a better life insurance agent
than i ever was and she's a better uh
one-on-one mentor to a lot of people i
tend to mentor in small groups or or
large audiences sheena gets really
nervous when it comes to that like if
she you know i wanted her to come into
pocket she was like i can't do the
podcast really she freaks out but i've
heard her speak before i know very good
you should see what she has to do in the
back in backstage just to get ready for
that talk she's so nervous really yeah
even for a zoom so it doesn't come
natural it doesn't come naturally but
when she's on it doesn't seem like that
okay yeah so you guys each have your
roles what's the one that overlaps um
on-boarding new associates okay so it's
because we want to make sure they get
both sides of our culture if anybody
needs help we overlap on that or if
she's busy again i'm not and we
overlapped but so that's on the business
side of things but the question was how
do you make the business and the
marriage work because if you were just
business partners cool great awesome but
now you got to go home with that person
sure right so here we go how does that
work sometimes in the business yeah
because we're we're
partners yeah she wants to talk to me
like she's
right she's like she's telling me what
to do okay right like babe your eyes
just got real wide
what's up hey hey i ain't i ain't one of
these associates
i hate that dude
about today yeah right and so uh i said
hey sweetheart you got two options here
you want to talk to the fool of me
you'll get the fool
you want to talk to the king and me
he'll get the king what do you want you
say this
wow please say that again an audience
listen up here you say this to your wife
say it again at this very moment you
want to talk to the fool of me you'll
get the fool you want to talk to the
king and me you'll get the king what do
you want
i want the kids
there you go
yes i do so let's go ahead and rephrase
that question yes
you say this let's rephrase that
question okay because to me because like
you're saying because men we tend to
take house and the people we take the
most amount of sensitivity to is the
woman closest to our heart of course
perhaps next time spirit like we can
take we can take an hour from some troll
or some competitor whatever it can be
but for my wife my girl yeah she says
something that has a potential it's
catastrophic yeah because she's so close
to my heart of course
but uh but to make to make it work you
just have to have some clear
expectations and and draw the line
if we got to deal with something listen
we're not going to talk about it at work
we're not going to talk about in front
of our associates in the boardroom we'll
talk about it at lunch when we go to
lunch together we'll talk about it when
we
when we get home when we have a break
throughout the day what does she ever
say to you and says
all right buddy you want to talk to the
fool and maybe you want to talk to the
queen and be like does she come back and
hit you with the taste of your own
medicine if you talk to her she is his
time out what did she say she was time
that's it time out i'm like that's her
that's her safe word gotcha
time out time out for me it's pineapple
but okay
let's say for it the thing is i want to
i want to add on is
the the leadership qualities that you
show with your wife you know she's going
to be responsive with them due to the
fact you know entrepreneur businessman
no matter how it is
but when she shows you
her
you know her moxie her moxie yeah i
guess you could say it's more like a
calm down so so that's at that at that
point we could say it could it could
somewhat be a conflict sure it could be
somewhere a conflict so you having you
going into a business partnership with
your wife could be pretty it's hairy it
could be you know i mean we make the
saying that uh we've been married for
seven years in business for eight
so in other words we have 21 years of
arguments under our belt because we're
together every day so we just compressed
time frames we've had the arguments that
people married for 20 years haven't had
in eight years of being together running
right yeah by the way are you you you're
in crypto
is your boyfriend also in crypto yeah
he's also you guys work together we do
work together so how does that work he
works great uh i know what he's good at
he knows what i'm good at and the same
thing with us we have the same common
goal as well on boarding people um so
when matt says like this is how
because matt how long you been with your
boyfriend by the way um
seven months okay so it's very new very
good this is 20 years well you know
packaged up so when matt says look
there's rules there's king there's
queens there's fools there's this are
you what are you taking from that you're
like oh that's a good point i guess i
gotta use that in my relationship and my
my business how does that work for you
um it works great because again i listen
to people like matt and you know i have
those as type of my mentors
because they clearly know how it's done
they've been doing it for so long so of
course i'm going to learn from them and
listen to what they're saying actually
is it is it um
wife first then business partner is it
business partner first then wife is it
50 50 how does it work
why first because we leave the office we
leave the we live at home but i sleep
with you yeah i have sex with you you
know yeah you don't have sex
anymore yeah
we have different ways to screw it but
yeah
okay
and for you how does that work it works
pretty well i mean we work together
business partner or
boyfriend first okay because everything
i mean started from being a boyfriend
girlfriend and then the rest and you
think that's the best approach why first
business partner because that's the most
it's just just being able to have of
course uh and if there's one that breaks
those rules it's it's me over she i'm
worse at it because i'm just i'm just
like
you know she
you know she's personal she's a little
bit more calm more structured you know
she's more you know stoic yeah correct
me yeah you know and that sometimes is
the detriment of me and sometimes i said
that because sometimes i say things i
regret
right in business and life to her to her
to her like would you reveal what that
what do you mean uh you know you don't
have to say exactly but like you know
things that gives us such a knee-jerk
reaction to me yeah because she is so
close to me and i'm so sensitive to her
sometimes i i just i need jerk reaction
to her more
readily sometimes than an associate or
partner or patrick yeah at the office i
won't need jerk patrick i'll think about
what i have to say to him sometimes to
my detriment i'll need your reaction to
my wife and she doesn't deserve it and
then walk us through that i feel like
i'm just going to make it up shut up
babe i'm busy yeah that's why she says
time out she's like hold on across
you're crossing the line yeah dress like
and
how often you get put in timeout all the
time
but it's important to have that dialogue
where it's like cool that's the safe
word time out okay let's regroup yeah
and does that automatically trigger like
a pavlovian response okay timeout means
act on your better behavior yeah and
right away she started doing that yeah
uh and i'm like thinking myself right
away like damn what an [ __ ] you are
so when timeout comes up you know that
you and i started thinking about my
daughters i started thinking about my
mom because i would never talk to my mom
and tell me i'd never talk to my
daughters that way she's rested
reminding me that i've heard you get
some intense coverage today i've got 21
year olds yeah you know i got to talk
about dress and attire and you know
going on and they just turned 21 i said
this is where you handle it going out
they might even have their first drink
distance
but we
you're right well it seems like you're
handling it the right way
[Music]